This is Valery.
She was 5 years old when
she received chemotherapy.
Valery would receive
chemotherapy treatments here
at the Clinica Medical Duarte
in the small border city of
Cúcuta, in Colombia.
On Jan. 23, 2020, doctors at the clinic
gave Valery a dose of Methotrexate,
a drug used to treat cancer.
Less than 24 hours later,
she was back in the hospital.
Days later, she was dead.
The drug Valery was given, Methotrexate,
was made by Naprod Life Sciences, a manufacturer headquartered in India
a country that supplies 20% of the world’s generic drugs.
But instead of being sterile, the medicine was contaminated
with bacteria and had
become dangerous.
In a months-long investigation, we learned this wasn’t an isolated incident.
Naprod’s medicines have been
linked to dire quality issues
with almost zero consequences.
This is the story of a drugmaker with
a dangerous track record
and how it keeps selling medicine, leaving families and doctors
to suffer the consequences.
Methotrexate is a drug
used to treat leukemia
and other cancers, and has
been around for decades.
When given as an injection, the conditions in which the drug is made
are always supposed to be sterile.
If the raw ingredients
aren’t tested adequately,
if a production line
isn’t cleaned properly,
if the water isn’t filtered thoroughly,
the life-saving medicine could
become potentially lethal.
Naprod Life Sciences plays a crucial,
if sometimes unnoticed,
role in the world’s drug supply chain.
None of its medicines are
for sale in the US.
Instead, it mostly sells directly to suppliers in low-income countries.
Batches of the cancer drug methotrexate,
made here in 2018 and 2019
were sent to clinics in Colombia.
Later, Colombian drug regulators confirmed that a dangerous bacteria
was found in the drug.
Doctors suspected more than
100 patients had suffered reactions
linked to the contaminated medicine.
A total of 4 kids died.
And the drug was later recalled.
My colleague Priyanka Pulla looked
into Naprod’s operations in India.
This is a plant that makes many
low cost cancer generics
for big brand names such as Intas,
Dr Reddy’s and Abbott.
Former employees of Naprod
whom we spoke to told us
that the quality control in this company was not up to the mark,
and was neglected greatly.
The former quality control employee spoke to us on condition of anonymity.
He was asked to hurry
through quality tests.
Indian regulators have frequently failed to detect and clamp down
on really dangerous quality issues.
State governments are very eager to attract the pharmaceutical industry
and to get them to set up their manufacturing plants
because it helps them
generate revenue and jobs.
And the state regulators are directly under these state governments.
These state regulators are not very well staffed. They are underfunded.
if you put these two things together,
it's a very dangerous cocktail
because this means that
India's huge manufacturing industry doesn't get as much oversight
as it needs.
This wasn’t the first time quality issues were found at Naprod.
In India, 3 separate batches of its cancer drugs failed quality tests
in 2017 and 2018.
In Ethiopia, researchers tested multiple samples of its chemo drug
and found only half of the
stated active ingredient.
Yet the company has not faced any serious consequences from regulators,
the big pharmaceutical companies buying Naprod’s products,
or public health warnings from the World Health Organization.
Naprod declined to
comment on Valery's case
or other cases in Colombia, citing ongoing legal proceedings.
The company said it has responded appropriately to quality concerns
raised by regulators and makes
high quality products.
So who is to blame for Valery’s death?
And how can people
in low-income countries
ensure their drugs are safe?
Despite its track record, Naprod continued selling medicines
around the world, cashing in on growing markets for generic cancer drugs.
And Valery’s case is
stuck in the labyrinth
of Colombian government bureaucracy.
The attorney general’s office received Valery's autopsy report four years ago.
It has listed her cause of death
as “under study.”
In the years that have passed, there have been few signs of progress in the probe.
In recent months, the attorney general's office has started interviewing families
and others involved.
But 2,500 miles away, a researcher in the US is trying to perfect
a test to help detect bad quality drugs before they reach patients.
The market for chemotherapy
products is increasing
and it's increasing in locations where often the regulatory agencies
are under-resourced,
particularly for analysis
of highly toxic chemotherapy products.
And so it's a very risky
situation right now.
The paper test her team
developed is a field lab kit
run on a sample of medicine, testing for the amount of active ingredient.
It costs as little as $2 and can be done easily by a nurse using a cellphone.
These are a field screening device that you can use to check a medicine quickly
and see if it looks good
or if it looks suspicious.
Nearly four years after Valery's death,
Naprod continues to sell its drugs to customers around the world.